COMING WEEKS.
>> Todd: DEAL IN JOE CONCHA,
JOE, HOW CAN THEY SAY THIS WHEN
THE VOTE HAD ABSOLUTELY NOTHING
TO DO WITH RACE AND EVERYTHING
WITH PARENTS WANTING KIDS TO GO
TO SCHOOL AND NOT WANTING THE
SCHOOL BOARD DISTRACTED BY
RENAMING SCHOOLS WHEN THE KIDS
AREN'T LEARNING ANYTHING?
>> Joe: RIGHT, RENAMING SCHOOLS,
SCHOOLS NAMED AFTER GEORGE
WASHINGTON, THE GUY WHO WON THE
REVOLUTIONARY WAR AND ABRAHAM
LINCOLN, THE GUY WHO FREED THE
SLAVES.
THANKFULLY PARENTS PUSHED BACK.
NICOLE HEMMER, NO RELATION TO
BILL HEMMER, WE MUST MAKE THAT
CLEAR.
SHE SAYS, IN PLACES LIKE LOUDOUN
COUNTY, CONSERVATIVE ACTIVISTS
HAVE DISCONTENT INTO A WAVE OF
REPUBLICAN VICTORIES.
SHE MAKES THIS ARGUMENT IN
LOUDOUN COUNTY IN SAN FRANCISCO.
YET JOE BIDEN WON LOUDOUN COUNTY
WITH 61% OF THE VOTE IN VIRGINIA
AND TOOK SAN FRANCISCO WITH 86
%
OF THE VOTE.
THIS IS A FAR LEFT IVY LEAGUE
SCHOLAR SAYING PARENTS' RIGHTS
AND MOVEMENT IN EDUCATION IS
DARK, FAR RIGHT EFFORT.
WE SAW IN VIRGINIA, GLENN
YOUNGKIN'S VICTORY, HE RAN ON
PARENT RIGHTS AND EDUCATION.
IN THE LAND OF NANCY PELOSI AND
SAN FRANCISCO, EDUCATION
EVISCERATES PARTY LINES.
PARENTS ARE WORRIED, LIKE ME,
U.S. IS 25th IN THE WORLD IN
READING, WRITING, SCIENCE AND
MATH AND PERHAPS MANY OF THEM,
ME INCLUDED DO NOT WANT THEM TO
VIEW THE WORLD BASED ON THE
PRISM OF RACE.
WE WANT THEM TO HAVE READING,
MATH AND SCIENCE.
THIS DISCONNECT AND NOW THEY ARE
SEEN AS ANTI-PARENT PARTY AND OF
COURSE
>> Senator: WILL PUBLISH THIS
SORT OF STUFF BECAUSE THEY ARE
DISCONNECTED, AS WELL.
>> Carley: SPEAKING OF
DISCONNECTED.
JOY BEHAR SAID THIS ON "THE
VIEW" YESTERDAY ABOUT MASKS.
>> I LISTEN TO THE LITTLE VOICE
IN MY HEAD THAT DOESN'T REALLY
FOLLOW 100% WHAT THEY TELL ME,
THEY KEEP CHANGING IT.
I WOULD WEAR A MASK, I MIGHT
INDEFINITELY.
>> Carley: GREAT, EVERYBODY CAN
WEAR A MASK IF THEY WANT, NOT
WEAR A MASK, HER RULE IS
APPARENTLY FOLLOW THE SCIENCE
UNTIL THE SCIENCE SAYS YOU CAN
TAKE YOUR MASK OFF.
>> Joe: RIGHT. THE SCIENCE SAYS
YESTERDAY NEW YORK CITY AVERAGED
1100 COVID CASES IN A CITY OF 8
MILLION.  THE NUMBER WAS 40,000
ONE MONTH AGO.
COVID IS DOWN IN TERMS OF
TRANSMISSION AND SPREAD.
LOCAL INDOOR MASK MANDATES ARE
BEING DROPPED, EXCEPT IN
SCHOOLS, WE CAN'T HAVE THAT.
IT IS SARKASM FRIDAY, IN CASE
YOU DIDN'T UNDERSTAND THAT.
YOU HAVE BEHAR AND THREE OTHER
WOMEN TALKING ABOUT IMPORTANCE
OF MASK AND THEY ARE SITTING
AROUND A TABLE INDOORS WITHOUT
ONE.
THIS IS COVID PANIC PORN AMERICA
IS SICK AND TIRED OF.
UNTIL YOU CAN FIND SOMEBODY FROM
THE RIGHT OR RIGHT OF CENTER
THAT CAN MAKE A DECENT ARGUMENT
AT THAT TABLE AND PUSH PACK ON
BEHAR, RATINGS AT THE VIEW WILL
CONTINUE TO PLUMMET.
IT WAS MORE INTERESTING WHEN
MEGAN McCAIN WAS THERE.
>> Todd: THE NOID AND WHAMMY GUY
FROM PRESS YOUR LUCK, DO YOU
AGREE?
>> Joe: WHAT IS PRESS YOUR LUCK,
SUNDS LIKE SOMETHING IN THE
'80s, THAT IS BEFORE M